sadio morel quand tu es journaliste et
spécialiste de l'afrique s'est vu
d'ailleurs sadio morel kanté bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être en direct ce matin
avec nous sur rt france laurent gbagbo
donc devant la cpi aujourd'hui qu'en
pensent les ivoiriens de cette deuxième
comparution
oui mais c'est une comparution que la
plupart la majorité des partisans de
gbagbo juste de trop parce que la vraie
l'acquittement généralement l'afrique en
compte parce qu' on puisse hommes avoir
une liberté conditionnelle et ne pas
pouvoir rentrer chez soi malgré un les
relances de gbagbo pour avoir d'abord
passe pas pour rentrer on a eu et un
goûter sans que la voulu rentrer 110
pouvoir maintenant la politisation
certains dans la tête de beaucoup
d'ivoiriens qui pense que c'est plus
sain possible politique que un procès
équitable du moment qui a eu 3000 morts
et qu'on en a attribué 301 balles mots
sans que 2700 autre n'ait fait l'objet
de poursuites et puis ils se disent que
c'est deux camps qui se sont affrontés
pourquoi y'a que gbagbo et son jeune
ministre blé goudé curité poursuivi et
non pas le camp en face ouattara et les
ex de l'époque
quels sont les scénarios sont
envisageables si la cour pénale
internationale des sites d'acquitter
laurent gbagbo il pourrait revenir en
politique je crois que laurent gbagbo
est un homme brisé
assagi et qui vous l'avez vu à boycotter
plusieurs fois les scrutins je crois que
la vie politique que va l'intéresser
mais un peu de loin pas d'implication
personnelle et il va plutôt sur
positionner en sage passe plus
les ivoiriens beaucoup de ses partisans
le considèrent en fait comme le deuxième
seulement de la de l'afrique
un hymne n'a de cesse d'appeler à la
paix bien qu'il ait oui oui côté
destructeur mais la dernière fois qu'il
a ajouté encore de revenir dans son pays
ça n'a pas pu avoir lieu et je crois
qu'il va se poster en langue de paix en
langue de réconciliation et tenait à ce
que l'équilibré socio politique de son
pays soit effectif et finalement les
événements de 2011 qui ont fait 3000
morts vous l'avez dit les il n'y aura
pas de deux responsables finalement jugé
devant une cour de justice comment est
ce que les ivoiriens voient cette cette
question qui n'est pas réglée et trouve
que c'est la justice des vainqueurs 1
gbagbo a perdu a perdu dans cette crise
là et que alassane aidés par les
puissances étrangères et a été l'homme
fort quand tu es à être longue fois en
poussant le bouchon jusqu'à faire un
troisième mandat qui est passé au là et
que ma grand un pour la france mène
france est empressé de saluer lieu de
féliciter tout de suite alors que
constitutionnellement c'est c'était
c'était forfaiture de de passer en force
pour imposer mandat et que et jusque
pour une énième fois
ouattara a été par jour parce que on se
souvient qu'il avait dit qu'il passerait
la main nouvelle génération qui se
présenterait pas quand germann il ya eu
l'avant de son premier premier ministre
hama amadou gon coulibaly dépenses qu'il
aurait pu laisser les choses se faire
autrement que de se présenter
personnellement et c'est la déception
c'est la cas par mois ils considèrent
que c'est l'accaparement du pouvoir par
alassane ouattara
étant donné que soupçonne également que
son petit frère qui est rentré comme
ministre de la défense en remplacement
au premier ministre
[Musique]
reiko qui est également ministre de la
défense c'est l'accaparement de l'état
par la famille ouattara et qu' ils
pensent aussi également que photocopies
donc tu aimerais ouattara qu est le
petit frère de hassan ouattara pourrait
être le prochain chef de l'état et que
c'est des choses inacceptables pour eux
que balles mots 1
dans tous les cas n'aurait pas fait ça
il estime que c'était un des plus grands
démocrates de la côte d'ivoire est ce
qu'ils vont être nombreux aujourd'hui
les partisans de laurent gbagbo à suivre
la décision de la cour pénale
internationale
oui les partisans de gbagbo ont toujours
été mobilisé 1
je me souviens avoir été à la haine et
qui a eu plus de 800 personnes dans plus
de 800 ivoiriens et non ivoiriens venus
du monde entier poursuivre l'ouverture
du procès en janvier 2016 2016 ou 2017
je me suis bleu de l'année mais j'y
étais et ils étaient nombreux à être là
et ils n'ont la mobilisation autour de
gbagbo n'a jamais faibli d'ailleurs et
c'est je crois que c'est ce qui a fait
peur à our head pouvoir le voir libre
est de toutes les façons aujourd'hui
gbagbo ne présente plus dans de menace
ou atteint les revenants sceptiques qui
rentre comme il avait souhaité avant les
élections du moment qu'il n'a pas plu je
crois qu'aujourd'hui al assad a le champ
libre au noir gérer la côte d'ivoire
comme il le veut et même mettre qu'il
veut y compris son frère si nos sept
secondes ses compatriotes ivoiriens
qu'ils ne font beaucoup ce ne font pas
confiance on la salle dans sa gestion
n'est que ça sera longue de la paix au
nez parce que henin elle n'arrive pas à
concilier abords de tentatives de
réconciliation qui a été mené avec bédié
notamment mais sans issue et jusque là
et que la libération sous conditions
obtenues de paquebot est également
perçu comme une décision politique
plutôt que comme une décision juridique
et qui pose aussi que c'est un
acharnement contre gbagbo que la
procureure et interjetté appel la
procureure sortons une feinte au
lancement est attendu à peine alors que
pour l'acquittement a eu lieu mais la
cour pense que la justice n'a pas été
dit il ya eu des problèmes tant dans le
fond que dans le droit et qu'il souhaite
le renouvellement de de ce procès l'a à
nouveau procès et mais est ce qu'il ya
des nouvellement c'est ce qu'on verra
tout à l'heure à 15h15 heure de france
si il y aura des nouveaux éléments le
plancher un nouveau procès on va voir
cela merci beaucoup en tout cas elle
salue montréal comptait d'avoir répondu
ce matin en direct à nos questions sur
rt france